hey it's Conan O'Brien welcome to Conan
O'Brien needs a friend joined as always
by my stalwart companions Matt Gourley
and Sona mosesian and a quick shout out
to Eduardo he's our genius uh sound
engineer here uh I thought you just
pushed a button when it was time for us
to record but I saw you it looked like
you were booking me an airline seat you
you were on the computer for about 10
minutes uh I genuinely caught off guard
by this shout out so that's okay yes
thank you this is the way I like my
shout outs is I like to catch someone
unawares but don't you just push a
button to record or is it a whole
process not quite it's a few buttons but
yeah uh you know sometimes we push a
button we push a fader up push fader
down okay what are you uh a DJ what is
happening I understand look at it it
can't be that complicated it is uh it's
it's not the most complicated but it
does require you know like for instance
other people in the
world back on all right that's cool so
that didn't change for us yeah none of
the listeners they will hear the voice
they'll hear it
[Music]
we heard nothing and it was like you
were the saddest kids musician Magician
of all time how about how about why
don't you tell us something give us a
riff give us one of your best one-liners
okay how about this four scores oh
that's really nice
that oh and Sona and I can just talk and
we don't have to hear him exactly could
we keep that like lock that button and
how do you actually put a screw into a
button so that it doesn't can you just
put a heavy Pebble on that button so
that it's always operating yeah I have
that by default no we haven't talked
about this before but is there a way to
affect my voice so I have more
testosterone uh wait the sound or just
so you actually as a human get more
tests you want to have more testosterone
there there is a way we can introduce
things like Reverb uh to your voice for
instance
hello hello well that just
sounds like I'm the same guy but I fell
in a well does that sound at all like
when you have your voice inside your
head talking yes and like criticizing
yourself let's do that this is me and
childhood go ahead okay
here we go
follow you
myself
[Music]
yes
that was fantastic yeah that was what it
was like your your voice inside your
head lives in like a giant grain style
it does yeah my head is a big empty
space and then there's just some old
Grain on the floor
um wow that was cool so here's a chorus
effect can you guys hear this yeah
test test test
oh okay you sound like Hal 9000
quarterly oh my God
Hal opened the pod bay Hal could cone
open the pod bay I'm sorry Corley I
can't open the pod bay I have to travel
all the way out to goddamn Jupiter and
you're the voice of the computer
that's right Corley
you'll be trapped with me forever oh my
and I'm in control of the ship
I've had all of your fancy Bakelite
clocks that you purchased at the Rose
Bowl swap meet and arranged fastidiously
in your house on your special Shelf
destroyed oh you dirty devil
what's that big space baby doing out
there it's growing it's a fetus now but
soon it'll grow to sell much more
Gorly
why don't
I have one question yes we're here in
deep space and you're in a spaceship and
it's the future and you're wearing a
cardigan
yeah
you're goddamn right I am you
okay Carly hey I got a question for you
yeah we're out in deep space you're a
computer that's right and you're wearing
up some kind of athleisure zip up
sweater it was sent to me by missing in
Maine
it's a freebie because I read an ad
higher forms of life always take
advantage of a freebie missing in Maine
athleisure wear for the computer in deep
space
that's that's fun it's fun to play with
this yeah I'll have more for you next
time I promise okay all right good well
that was fun playing with the The Voice
we're going to work on that Eduardo but
also a serious shout out to you do an
amazing job thank you
um insult to come
uh my guest today just now you're just
handing out IOU insults instead of even
having yeah
oh my God that's both insulting and just
rude and lazy yeah and lazy oh yeah well
I'll get you later sick burn to come